el anuncio fue hecho esta mañana en el
Canal de Telegram por el general de las
fuerzas terrestres del ejército
ucraniano general Alexander que ayer
había estado con esas tropas que pelean
El bambú ella él dijo que había habido
una contraofensiva y que habían logrado
hacer retroceder algunas de las tropas
en algunos bloques de la ciudad de
backmud Hasta el momento se había dicho
que el 80% ya estaba en poder de las
fuerzas rusas especialmente de esas
fuerzas paramilitares Wagner esto
después de más de 10 meses de pelea
continua por el poder de esta población
de 80.000 habitantes en el corazón del
donbas también que era famosa
irónicamente con sus producciones de
champaña pero también por su minería lo
que nos dicen
que han estado allí en los últimos días
y que habían estado allí en la noche de
ayer y que encontramos en la vecina
ciudad de Constantinopla era que sí que
sí la presión hecho lograr retroceder a
las tropas rusas en algunos pequeños
sectores pero que la situación seguía
siendo extremadamente difícil como
también lo había dicho el general otro
de los integrantes de ese Batallón que
está en la cercanías o que pelea también
dentro de vacunos nos había dicho que
allí adentro no hay posiciones que los
ucranianos entran pelean ataquen y
vuelven a salir que no hay lugar Exacto
para donde quedarse y cuando le
preguntaba cómo estaba él decía 50 50
porque como nos dijo otro de los
combatientes allí dice que si bien esta
idea de una contraofensiva causaba un
alivio dentro de la población ucraniana
para los soldados que están peleando
allí significa enormemente y un gran
sacrificio especialmente en vidas
humanas y se le llegaba en su momento a
encharcar los ojos también lo que vimos
hoy fue llegada de refuerzos para esas
tropas que están o en la cercanía No
sabía muy bien pero este Batallón o
estos hombres venían desde el occidente
del país nunca habían estado en la
región del donbas y se les veía con esa
incertidumbre de saber qué era lo que se
iban a esperar encontrar allí pero
decían vamos a exactamente a donde no
sabemos si a las afueras o dentro de ese
pequeño territorio que todavía tiene
Ucrania